neue indizien für leben auf dem mars
asteroiden anschläge lösten dort eine
tsunami welle aus ist damit das rätsel
um die mars oberfläche gelöst jetzt bei
pixum science fiction forscher haben es
herausgefunden und zwar dass der mars
vor 4,3 milliarden jahren von zwei
asteroiden getroffen wurde nicht
gleichzeitig sondern im abstand von etwa
ein paar millionen jahren zu diesem
ereignis kommen wir gleich noch mal
aber schauen wir uns mal den planeten
etwas genauer an der mars ist einer
unserer nächsten nachbarn im
sonnensystem und schon lange stellt sich
die menschheit die frage gibt oder gab
es leben auf dem mars ist der mars
vielleicht sogar der planet der der erde
am ähnlichsten ist wie ist die
oberfläche des roten planeten entstanden
also wie erd- ähnlich kann der mass
gewesen sein sieht er doch ganz anders
aus als unser planet aber obwohl der
mars nur halb so groß wie die erde ist
gibt es gar nicht so viele unterschiede
zu unserem heimatplaneten der maas hat
eine atmosphäre
auch wenn sie nur wirklich sehr dünnes
zum größten teil nämlich 95,9 prozent
besteht sie aus kohlenstoff stickoxid
jahreszeiten hat der planet auch und ein
tag dauert etwas mehr als 24 stunden
aber es ist sehr kalt auf dem mars im
sommer können die höchsttemperaturen
schon einmal auf 20 grad celsius steigen
die durchschnittstemperatur liegt aber
bei etwa nur 50 grad celsius also minus
50 grad schaut man sich die bilder der
marsoberfläche aber an könnte das auch
eine aufnahme einer wüsten topographie
hier auf der erde sein und wasser die
essenz des lebens scheint es dort oben
auch zugeht die nasa raumsonde mars
reconnaissance orbiter kurz mmo hat
beispielsweise spuren von salz sie
traten gefunden
ein spektrometer genauer gesagt das
kompakt renaissance imaging spectrometer
zeichnete infrarot wellen im bereich von
10 mikrometern auf diese wellenlänge ist
typisch für salz hydrate wie
beispielsweise magnesium perchlorat im
wort salz hydrate versteckt sich auch
schon die sensation
nitrate sind stoffe die meistens wasser
enthalten das heißt diese salze umstände
müssen in verbindung mit flüssigem
wasser entstanden sein es gibt also auch
jetzt noch flüssiges wasser auf dem mars
davon gab es wohl auch mal deutlich mehr
das team der nasa curiosity mission fand
im oktober 2015 nicht nur salz hydrate
sondern ganze sehen herzstück der
mission curiosity ist der gleichnamige
rover er seit drei jahren die karge
landschaft des mars untersucht die auf
fotos entdeckten sehen sind zwar nicht
mehr in einem zustand den wir hier auf
der erde kennen sie sollen sich aber
früher in einem ähnlichen zustand
befunden haben die eben hier auf der
erde also mit wasser von rund drei
milliarden jahren hätten diese sogar
rund 10.000 jahre auf dem roten planeten
über dauert dieser fund könne die these
dass es früher einmal leben auf dem mars
gegeben hat und jetzt auch die neue
these bekräftigen tsunamis auf dem mars
und jetzt sind wir wieder beim einstieg
des videos angelangt bei den zwei
asteroiden forscher haben kürzlich im
fachmagazin nature über mega tsunamis
auf dem mars berichtet von rund 4,3
milliarden jahren hätte es auf dem
planeten mars eine kolossale oder genau
zwei naturkatastrophen geben diese zwei
asteroiden sollen der abstand von ein
paar millionen jahren in den damals noch
existierenden ozean gestürzt seien die
folge ein gigantischer krater mit einem
durchmesser von rund 30 kilometern
jeweils dieser wurde in den ozean boden
geschlagen und darauf folgt jeweils ein
mega zunahme dieser tsunami sondern
bruchstücke der oberfläche noch bis zu
500 kilometer weit getragen haben und
dass eben genannte szenario hätte sich
daneben auch beim zweiten einschlag
abgespielt beim rückgang hätten die
wassermengen mehrere meter breite spuren
gezogen
diese furchen würden noch heute den
meeresarm der früher bestehenden
gewässer zeigen eine küstenregion oder
einen saum wie der der jetzt in den
regionen kreis planie cia- und axi dalia
planeten entdeckt wurde könnte
tatsächlich zuvor noch nie gefunden
werden wie seht ihr das was glaubt ihr
formte die marsoberfläche waren es
tatsächlich die wassermengen oder können
eine sonnenstürme oder die mars
atmosphäre gewesen sein die die
oberfläche geformt haben lass uns
darüber in den kommentaren diskutieren
was habt ihr darüber erfahren und
schreibt mir auch eure eigenen
vorschläge in die kommentare wenn euch
das video gefallen hat dann lass gern
einen daumen
nach oben da abonniert klicks um ist er
kostenlos und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran